hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
remember when I said I didn't like the
Flintstones cartoon
obviously you do well there's another
classic old cartoon that I also find I
really can't stand mr. Magoo obviously
not as big a backlash he never did
anything for me because it's basically
just one joke he can't see the rest of
the time he just sort of smiles and
looks happy so there's no real comedic
suffering on his part or even really
that much to the people around him he
falls he misses something but he's
always okay where's the comedy how does
that get a laugh the only thing less
funny than mr. Magoo is giving him a
ridiculous film budget to explain how
unfunny he is ah if you can't see what's
wrong with this flick then you're as
nearsighted as this dumbass idea you
know the term if it's not broken don't
fix it well there is a term in the 90s
that went if it's broken Disney's
founder screenplay
this was during their especially bad run
of horrible live-action movies and trust
me when I say this is certainly the
topping flag of shit mountain it was an
age where ideas to make movies avid was
at an all-time low well almost all time
low let's tumble into mr. Magoo Wow the
first second literally the first second
of this film annoys me
ah there's only five thousand 492 to go
good night mrs. wonder bottom I'm gonna
stare do I've ever seen I guess it
figures that we start off on the cartoon
during the credits but honestly it's
kind of distracting that while Leslie
Nielsen stars as Magoo in the movie he
doesn't do his voice in the credits I
know it's a nitpick but it just sort of
emphasizes the direct side-by-side
comparison of how much these two don't
have in common it's like if in a Popeye
movie they start with a cartoon in the
original voice but then suddenly cut to
someone completely different
yo I'm Popeye and shit we do finally get
the live-action version starting too
late Leslie Nielsen who's apparently a
rich canned vegetable entrepreneur cop
there's so many who donated a museum
wing to a rare Ruby please quiz it no
actually it's corundum the hell is that
woman wearing ramani who the nearsighted
kook is in this movie her head looks
like a cartoon iris that got stuck
halfway through now what the fuck's ours
we see Magoo look around the museum
while uh-oh he mistook something for
something else
Wow what's a bad joke doesn't get all
the real quick oh my gosh would you look
at that what and no your eyes aren't as
bad as his that is in fact Jennifer
Gardner pre career obviously I'm Stacy
stump and a ho D truck this is my nephew
Waldo ha ha welder Magoo
it isn't honor oh god what ethnicity do
they have from mocking if the vague
accent the weird hair that Chinese
crackerjacks sailor suit it's like the
quiz hack had a rack of stereotypes that
insult all races at once may all the
exhibits in this hall shine with the
light of human knowledge ha
he tries cutting the ribbon but ends up
cutting an electrical cord if it told me
the scene looks more cutesy or horrified
haha dozen people were in critical
condition charming I joke headstart
consequences public telephone oh he
confuses a mummy's tomb for a telephone
booth and the door closes in behind him
later that night we see a children's
stage play version of Catwoman and Bane
trying to break into the museum to steal
the Ruby
luckily she finds some pee-wee's
Playhouse dinosaurs to hide behind as
she moves forward with the robbery by
the way you ever noticed how bad movies
have really poorly designed museums
Batman and Robin also have the same rare
jewel / dinosaurs / Egyptian art /
exotic plant life exhibit a little
cluttered don't you think look who
finally comes out of the tomb wait he
was in that box with the mummy for five
hours
that's more than a vision problem that's
a mental psychosis and the robbers get
away by knocking the guard into the
phony styrofoam exhibit the next day we
see the garner is so distressed that she
put on her distraught tylenol hat and
investigators come to look at the see
chucks do pack FBI Gustav and des CIE
Ernie no god damn it I'm sick of you
showing up in shit you're good actor you
have style in class please tell me
you're doing stage work somewhere I'll
gladly see it just to apologize for the
fact that your aunt is dick demon the
CIA has no jurisdiction on American soil
this could very well become an
international incident not if you don't
get in my way fancy pants
oh no donut
you did not just Ernie Hudson okay you
say that for a Chris Tucker not an Ernie
Hudson hmm
hurry yeah meanwhile we see the two
robbers talk about last night's heist
there's nothing in the papers
trap they're trying to lows into a false
sense of security and then bust us we
make a careless move that's yesterday's
paper
that's right folks you just witnessed a
film where they actually played the wah
wah wah music little-known fact the
composer actually killed himself three
minutes later after being forced to
write that piece she gets him to hand
over the giant ring pop and kicks him
off the boat but he tries to take her
down with him and the jewel falls into
Magoo's boat who just happened to be
passing by this guy is like an unfunny
duo seeking missile blasts sure what a
janitor they hope they can get back at
the Opera that night where Magoo is not
only attending but also performing yeah
a little confusing seeing how we've
never seen him saying and it's never
explained whether or not he can sing in
fact according to this movie mr. Magoo
is well-rounded enough to be put in any
situation at any location except what he
actually does for a living yeah his job
allows him to do all this Richie stuff
but we're never actually allowed to see
what he does he's said to be the canned
vegetable King wouldn't it make sense to
have them in a canned vegetable factory
then there's gotta be some comedic
opportunities there but no fuck you we
got a castrated episode of I spy to
watch just spotted a conspicuous white
male dirty clothes needs hair cutting
we're look to your left
pulse you just got good the lady feet
disguises herself and tries to get an
interview with him while the male thief
is a little bit more direct just showing
the audience what that does okay but he
can't get past his low-key horns and big
shock he gets knocked out which causes
him to accidentally turn on a giant fan
yeah because if there's anything every
opera performance needs what the
sensitivity of the singers voices
it's a giant loud hard to control wind
machine why don't all around the terrace
the next day he meets up with the
thieves still thinking she's a reporter
and she tries to put the moves on him
true nella you know this film is so dull
and useless I'm actually more interested
in the backstory of the fish did he have
a good life do you think his family
appreciates what the sacrificing of his
body is going to well did you see what
they did with Howard's body yes yes I
did please tell me he's at least being
used to feed a poor starving family no
he's he's being used for a live-action
version of mr. Magoo ha ha ha Warner
Brothers are Disney just we also get a
little info about that fief as well it's
LuAnn lisore the Black Widow she kills
all of her male accomplices no one has
ever been able to finger her what a
shame
they died before they finger her
like that for their fall like a house
okay alright ladies and gentlemen we
will be right back with a Miss Penelope
crew
Oh
ladies and gentlemen my next guest has
been in such movies as Vanilla Sky
Pirates of the Caribbean on Stranger
Tides of the fuck am i doing back to the
moment we see Magoo's nephew is getting
friendly with garner as he takes her out
to get her dressed as those are the
clown's underwear your governement
thanks mr. Magoo stole the star of
Kristen and you do you think he did it
well do I need your help every time I
see her I'm insulted I just don't know
who I'm insulted for what's that country
balki was from me pose yeah
I'm insulted for meatballs finally
enough Nizhny I can identify as being
defaced just throw Jeff Dunham or Carlos
Mencia in there the trio of unfunny bad
taste will be complete so while everyone
tries to break into his house and find
the Ruby but GU tries his best to rip
off the mr. bean cooking see black yeah
how long till he switches to the porno
Channel next I want you to touch a big
long cock inside me okay if it insist
come on get your rear interfere do you
think the chicken had a good life do you
think his family appreciates what his
body is being used for did your fine
Daniel's body use so are they put him to
good use
well you see Disney ah the mail thief
grabs the jewel and drives off leaving
the rest of them to drive a giant
eggplant I dip the good Oh what yeah
the giant eggplant no you didn't smoke
anything cuz that would mean I would
have had to uh smoke too - this is the
closest connection to his job that we
ever get apparently it's part of an
eggplant delivery service well no wonder
he's so frigging rich with fucking
ingenious ideas like that I'm surprised
Steve Jobs never picked this guy up
hey play delivery servant the fucking is
fired I've been this impressed with an
idea since a patient at the mental ward
asked me if I want to buy a cloud
the thief gets away but the woman
convinces them that she's working for
the FBI and that she knows that the
jewels going to be auctioned off by a
crime lord every billionaire gangster in
the world is coming except the most
powerful of them all Ortega Peru piranha
no one's ever seen him he never goes
anywhere so if we could get someone to
impersonate Peru we could get close to
the gem and recover it who don't you why
not the blind man who's proven time and
time again though he's a constant threat
to anything in anyone he comes across
yeah I'm down with this mr. Peru never
goes anywhere that's right I never go
anywhere so when I go somewhere everyone
thinks I am nowhere when I'm really they
so they're under the impression that
mobster billionaires are bad we dose or
doochie impersonators to be made a saint
in the Catholic Church you have to have
a for miracles I understand it two of
them was card trick and now we take a
look at just who's running this song up
now can McDowell yeah I've seen this guy
in so many my reviews I should just have
a warm glass from the curl the milk bar
waiting for when you've changed your
clothes these lovely ladies are waiting
to serve you with chilled champagne in
the solarium thank you
ah apparently there was another scene in
that woman's ass hey someone told me the
rest of this movie came out of someone's
behind I believe it every time I kill a
man I tattoo his portrait on my body
I bet firuze got some pretty nice
tattoos so Magoo takes the time to draw
a tattoo real quick of okay joke you
have to be more clear if we're not gonna
laugh at you we can't make out what that
is is it a drawing of the Alamo Sponge
Bob spaceship an explosion of pubic hair
okay movie you're forcing me to look
really close and wrinkly Leslie Nielsen
chest not cool Knapp but we're not of
good terms right now but the female
thief comes in and steals it for herself
okay then if you will stop her good job
there she's what is with this woman's
wardrobe a power ranger uniform has more
dignity than that
they have a look chase down the mountain
in the middle of the women's
snowboarding competition because digest
Disney finds it funnier when women hurt
but she ends up getting away while the
rest are left cold please I don't know
which one was it
of course pie was frozen today until my
obligation and if you can believe it the
film is still going really I mean yes
snuck into the hideout you had the big
chase what's your motivation behind
making more of this film do you think
it's just punishment from the director
like every time it's kids act up he'd
say knock it off I'm adding another
minute to mr. Magoo
oh they find the thief and yet another
disguise and trying to figure out where
she's heading to those receipts for
Brazil why would she go to Brazil she's
going to Peru she'd go to Brazil to go
to Peru
exactly but why to get more heart for
the Ruby Peru exactly but then why go to
Brazil Peru it's in Brazil Peru's in
Brazil just go there yeah I'll put you
on the fucking plane myself to go so
they finally get to the damn place where
yet another crime lord looks to possess
the ruby do you have the 15 million
oh gee was he hiding something in that
suit I couldn't tell
well that's going on it seems to come
across the little people in bad costumes
part of the house is a trivia before
Game of Thrones this was actually Peter
Dinklage's most famous for the
accidentally sneaks into the room of a
guy who's about to get married and yeah
you can all guess where this is going
oh do come on eh no way but not too
rough it wouldn't last
hide me I love you to John McCain just
lost my wedding the way he escapes on a
raft but when you know it it's just
about to go over a waterfall how the
hell is he gonna get out of this
I always promised an old man and a
wedding dress going over a waterfall
this opportunity will never happen again
yo tell em are they get the jewel back
the nephew owned a stereotype get
together we cut back to the shitty
cartoon this was based off of and get a
lot of this we get a disclaimer at the
end saying that the film was never meant
to insult anyone with poor eyesight
first of all if you're going to
apologize to anyone apologize to the
audience who now have to cut their dicks
off in order to feel something second if
you're going to say something to the
visually impaired don't write it in tiny
lettering that they probably can write
mr. Magoo the cartoon isn't funny took
mr. Magoo the movie isn't funny
mr. Magoo is not funny it's poor
slapstick with a shoddy script and
characters and aren't even attempted to
be made interesting once in a while
there's a good stunt but when you put a
painfully obnoxious cartoon sound effect
over it it loses all comedic value I
wish I was as blind as a bat so I won't
have to see this stupid ass piece of
shit if you'll excuse me I'm gonna do
the worst thing I can think of bludgeon
an old blind man to death I'm a
nostalgia critic I remember so you don't
have to time for another day of doing
nothing at the canned vegetable Factory
all right yo faster you're gonna pay for
that movie over there looks like the
nostril critic hey didn't think I could
see did you I'm just playing it up for
the handicap sticker in my car I can see
everything
yeah perfect 20/20 vision can you even
see the blonde as it spurts out your now
yes delicious yummy bored those people
I'm actually quite a psychopath back o
me crazy mister nostril critic Khaled
with a crazy man strangle an orphan girl
because he thinks she's queen of the
people yes yes you weren't around when
we are there
it's a pitchfork with your asses name on
it
yeah let me give it back
no one has ever been able to finger her